[Musique]
pierre bourdieu est sans conteste l'un
des plus grands noms de la sociologie
française
l'auteur qui a travaillé sur un grand
nombre d'objets qui a étudié beaucoup de
phénomènes sociaux nous laisse toute une
série de concept très intéressant sur le
point de vue théorique mais parfois un
peu difficile d'accès les concepts
d'habitus dépasse social de chant de
capitaux ou de violences symboliques
sont essentielles en sciences sociales
et parfois sous peu maîtrisée par les
élèves
cette vidéo propose donc de faire le
point sur l'un des concepts essentiels
de la théorie bourdieusienne la violence
symbolique
pierre bourdieu commence à terroriser
son concept de violence symbolique dans
la reproduction ouvrages et qu'il
réalise en 1970 avec la collaboration de
jean claude passeron
dans cet ouvrage il va nous parler de la
violence symbolique
appliqué au système scolaire nous
reviendrons plus tard sur cet exemple et
nous donnerons d'autres exemples
d'application de ce concept de violence
symbolique mais comment peut-on définir
ce concept pierre bourdieu va définir le
concept de violence symbolique comme un
rapport de force entre groupes sociaux
converti en rapport de sens il ya
vraiment une modification de nature de
quelque chose qui est arbitraire et qui
devient finalement légitime
ce changement se produit avec la
complicité active de ceux sur qui
ce changement de sens va porter
autrement dit les dominants vous imposer
quelque part leurs critères leur choix
leur comportement comme légitime et il
vole imposer vos classes dominées qui
vont elles mêmes le vivre comme quelque
chose de tout à fait normal et naturel
je vous propose la définition suivante
qui pourrait être notre commun
dénominateur pour caractériser et
définir ce concept de violence
symbolique la violence symbolique est un
mécanisme de domination sociale ou un
groupe social impose aux
autre groupe des choix des opinions des
comportements en les faisant passer pour
légitimer universel alors qu'ils sont
situés socialement le point essentiel de
la théorie de bourdieu c'est le fait que
cette violence ce choix arbitraire de
normes et de valeurs se fait avec le
consentement des personnes qui vont être
victime de ce choix et c'est bien là que
la théorie et tous les travaux de
bourdieu font partie d'une grande
entreprise de dévoilement qui va mettre
à jour les mécanismes de domination qui
sont souvent en sous-entendus dans nos
relations sociales
deux exemples maintenant pour illustrer
ce concept de violence symbolique eux
mêmes tirés des travaux de pierre
bourdieu le premier dans la reproduction
bien bourdieu nous dit que l'école est
une institution qui se base sur la
violence symbolique
en effet on va décider de certains
savoirs qu'ils devront être enseignée
qui devront être acquis par les élèves
et ses savoirs bains sont ceux d'une
classe et principalement de la classe
bourgeoise en effet on va décider que le
français la géographie l'histoire sont
les éléments essentiels à enseigner or
ce sont des connaissances qui ont
surtout une importance dans les familles
les plus aisées les enfants des familles
lisez auront plus de facilité parce qu'à
la maison on parle un champ un français
plus châtié plus corriger plus maîtrisée
on voyage donc on acquiert beaucoup de
références qui permettent la pratique de
la géographie on a une culture
importante donc pour les matières
classiques ou l'histoire c'est un
avantage aussi avantages que n'ont pas
les classes dominées or ces classes
dominées vont se dire directement mais
écoutez moi je ne suis pas fait pour
pour l'école parce que je ne comprends
rien à ce que vous
dit je ne sais pas parler français je ne
suis pas fait pour ça sauf que le pas
fait pour ça c'est plutôt la matière
enseignée qui n'est pas fait pour eux
aussi vous voulez un puisqu'elle est
celle d'une autre classe sociale dans un
autre ouvrage est certainement un
ouvrage qui constitue l'un des travaux
les plus intéressants de pierre bourdieu
là c'est mon avis personnel
la distinction pierre bourdieu va
s'intéresser aux goûts artistiques
nous disons souvent dans la nature tous
les goûts s'y retrouvent un les goûts et
les couleurs ça ne se discute pas belles
pierres brutes du prend le parti d'en
discuter et nous montre qu'en fait le
bon goût le goût artistique un qui
serait quasi inné et qui viendrait par
par nature d'une manière très intuitive
mais un second est lié à une classe
sociale qui va décider finalement de
manière arbitraire ce qu'est le bon goût
évidemment les autres classes sociales
et classes plus populaires les classes
dominées n'auront pas accès à ce bon
goût et seront toujours considéré comme
ayant des goûts très grossier et
régulière alors que ce sont les goûts
des autres encore une fois qui leur sont
imposées avec leur consentement
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
intéressé qu'elle vous a permis de mieux
comprendre ce qu'on sait c'est que c'est
essentiel de violence symbolique
n'oubliez pas le pouce bleus s'il vous
avait apprécié la vidéo ça permet de
faire monter la chaîne est de rendre
encore plus démocratique finalement que
ces concepts intéressants de sciences
sociales je voulais aussi les
commentaires pour partager ou échanger
ou même corrigé le professeur si il ya
quelquechose éléments qui n'ont pas été
suffisamment bien dit ou précis vous
pouvez également vous rendre sur la
société que vous trouverez directement
la synthèse qui vous permettra d'avoir
une trace écrite de tout ce qui a été
dit dans cette vidéo
évidemment vous retrouver le lien dans
les commentaires en dessous de la vidéo
je vous remercie pour votre intérêt et à
très bientôt
[Musique]